por fin llegamos al último problema de
esta sección número 3 del examen 2 así
que estamos en el problema número 20
este es el último problema de esta
sección y dicen en el colegio linden hay
75 mujeres más que la cantidad de
hombres si hay n hombres inscritos
entonces en términos de en qué
porcentaje de los alumnos inscritos son
hombres qué porcentaje de los alumnos
inscritos son hombres y no sé por qué
siento que me voy a enfermar de algo
pero espero que no para poder seguir con
estos vídeos a ver dice hay n hombres
inscritos vamos a apuntarle aquí
n
es la cantidad de hombres inscritos es
la cantidad de hombres inscritos de
hombres muy bien y si n es la cantidad
de hombres qué cantidad de mujeres hay
bueno pues el problema dice en la
primera frase que en el colegio linden
hay 75 mujeres más que la cantidad de
hombres es decir si lo que queremos
saber es la cantidad de mujeres que hay
en el colegio linden entonces la
cantidad de mujeres cuántas mujeres va a
haber si nosotros sabemos que tenemos n
hombres pues va a haber n que es la
misma cantidad de hombres más 75 porque
dice que tenemos 75 mujeres más que
hombres y yo lo que quiero saber es qué
porcentaje de los alumnos inscritos son
hombres que bueno si lo que quiero saber
es el porcentaje y lo queremos ver en su
forma decimal esencialmente lo que hay
que calcular es la cantidad de hombres
que tenemos
hombres que tenemos entre la cantidad de
alumnos inscritos totales que tenemos
entonces lo voy a poner como la cantidad
total de alumnos la cantidad total de
alumnos que tenemos y bueno esto es lo
mismo que la cantidad de hombres pero
nosotros sabemos que la cantidad de
hombres es n entonces va a ser n entre
la cantidad total de alumnos inscritos
que tenemos si tenemos en de hombres y
tenemos n 75 mujeres entonces en total
tenemos n + n 75 alumnos inscritos y
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que n
entre 2 n + 75 pero date cuenta que este
número de trabajo va a ser más grande
que éste por lo tanto estamos dando en
su forma decimal el porcentaje de los
alumnos inscritos que son hombres si yo
lo que quiero es en términos de
porcentaje habrá que multiplicar esto
dicho de otra manera se multiplicó esto
por 100 me va a quedar que 100 n entre 2
en 75 es el porcentaje de alumnos
hombres que están inscritos en el
colegio en linden que es justo lo que yo
quiero y por cierto es el inciso iv y
bueno no sé qué hacer con todo este
largo tiempo extra que me queda por lo
que espero que tengas cosas más útiles
que hacer que ver - ser nada en un vídeo
así que mejor voy a parar este vídeo
aquí y nos vemos en el próximo vídeo
donde seguiremos con la siguiente
sección del ese arte hasta la próxima